monsieur le
rapporteur
général mes chers
collègues nous recevons ce matin
Monsieur François Villeroi de galau
gouverneur de la Banque de France je me
permets de vous saluer monsieur le
gouverneur de vous remercier de votre
présence et de vous adresser ainsi qu'à
l'ensemble des personnels de la Banque
de
France
au nom de notre commission mes meilleurs
vœux pour cette nouvelle année votre
audition ce matin est désormais
traditionnel puisque nous avons le
plaisir depuis quelques années de vous
retrouver au mois de
janvier nous souhaitons entendre votre
analyse sur l'état de l'économie ainsi
que sur la nature et les conséquences de
la politique monétaire actuellement
menée l'inflation que le système
européen de banque centrale a pour
mission euh en tout cas affirmé de
ramener à 2 %
décroîrait fortement puisque vos
prévisions macroéconomique font état
d'une diminution de l'inflation moyenne
de 5,7 % en 2023 à 2,5 % en
2024 pour faire diminuer l'inflation la
Banque centrale européenne a mené une
politique monétaire que l'on peut
qualifier de très restrictive augmentant
les taux directeurs de 450 points de
base entre juill 2022 et septembre 2023
ce resserrement monétaire sans précédent
n'a pas été sans effet sur le volume de
crédit immobilier octroyés notamment
passant de 22 milliards d'euros en mai
de 22 à 8,6 milliards d'euros en
décembre dernier l'investissement des
ménages selon vos estimations c'est
ainsi contracté de 3,6 % en 2023 et sa
baisse se poursuiverit pour atteindre
4,1 % en
2024 quant à l'investissement privé vous
estimez qu'il devrait augmenter de
seulement 0,5 % en 2024 après une hausse
de plus de 4 % en 2023 alimenté par des
taux de marge élevé il est donc à
craindre que cette politique monétaire
dont vous nous direz peut-être pourquoi
elle a été si restrictive de conduisent
à une stagnation de la croissance
française qui selon vos provisions ne
devrait pas dépasser 0,9 % en 2024
0,7 % selon le consensus des économistes
le chôage qui atteint désormais 7,4 %
pourrait également augmenter vous
déclariez pourtant dans la presse en
septembre dernier nous sommes je vous
cite sur le chemin de vaincre
l'inflation sans provoquer de récession
ni de chômage massif donc c'est
évidemment une question d'appréciation
sur lequel nous aimerions évidemment
vous vous entendre figure également au
nombre de vos attributions la gestion du
système des paiements ainsi que la
régulation du système bancaire à ce
titre nous serons heureux de vous
entendre sur l'entrée dans la deuxème
phase de l'euro numérique les banques
vous le savez qui disent avoir été peu
associé lors de la phase 1 paraissent à
tout le moins réservé sur ce projet nous
vous laisserons nous expliquer son
intérêt notamment pour le citoyen
par ailleurs le secteur bancaire
européen s'est fait peur l'an dernier à
la suite des faillites de banques
américaines en lien avec la remontée des
taux et avec celle plus proche de nous
de crédit Suisse la table ronde que la
Commission a organisé sur ce sujet en
mai dernier nous a quelque peu
évidemment rassuré mais les voix sont
discordantes sur la transposition
transposition des accords internationaux
de b 3 qui doivent intervenir au plus
tard fin 2024 4 en Europe certains
craignent toujours l'application d'un
modèle de réglementation anglo-saxon
inadapté à la France d'autres estiment
au contraire qu'il pourrait être fait
davantage notamment en matière de climat
par exemple en pondérant de façon
différentes les actifs verts et brun
dans le calcul des ratios de fonds
propre peut-être pourrez-vous nous
éclairer vous votre sentiment sur ces
sujets je vous cède donc la parole sans
plus attend Monsieur le Gouverneur les
sujets sont sont
nombreux avant de prendre les questions
de nos collègues cette audition est bien
évidemment mais comme chaque année
retransmise sur le site internet du
Sénat je vous
remercie j'y suis euh monsieur le
Président merci de votre accueil de vos
propos monsieur le rapporteur général
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs vous
l'avez dit cette audition annuelle au
mois de janvier est devenue une
tradition presque un rit républicain il
est en tout cas essentiel pour moi parce
qu'il marque un peu la rentrée de de
l'année merci aussi de vos vœux je
formule bien sûr tous les mien d'abord
personnel pour chacun de vous et
collectif pour notre cher pays dans
l'environnement qui va rester turbulent
en 2024 nous aurons plus que jamais
besoin d'ajouter au pessimisme de
intelligence l'optimisme de la volonté
alors pour marquer le début de l'année
nous sommes venus avec Véronique benï
CEN muni d'un modeste cadeau monsieur le
Président qu'on distribuera tout à
l'heure je dis tout de suite qu'il est
sérieux à l'image de la Banque de France
c'est le dernier que sais-je qui est
paru actualisé sur la Banque de France
je vous souhaite d'avoir d'autres
lectures aussi en 2024 mais celle-ci
peut peut-être vaut ça ne vaut pas 150 €
Mons non non non c'est un cadeau modeste
compatible je pense avec nos règles
déontologiques des deux
côtés non je sais pas quelle est la la
valeur marchande Véronique ça doitê ça
doit être de l'ordre de la diaines ou
quinzaines d'euros
bon mais mais vous verrez le contenu est
d'une grande richesse
bon plus plus sérieusement
et dans mon propos introductif alors je
traiterai certain un des sujets que vous
avez évoqué pas tous mais ensuite notre
discussion permettra d'y revenir je
voulais peut-être d'abord parler du
paysage
conjoncturel en ce début d'année qui
tend plutôt à se stabiliser euh et que
cette relative
stabilisation je j'y viendrai ensuite
permet et requierre je crois de traiter
nos défis économiques de moyen et long
terme si je commence par la conjoncture
il y a un an beaucoup redoutait pour la
France et l'Europe un scénario noir qui
ajouterait la récession et une inflation
durable environné en plus de beaucoup
d'incertitudes alors aujourd'hui
évidemment les incertitudes sur la
conjoncture n'ont pas disparu mais elles
tend un peu à se dissiper une des
preuves en étant que nous avons très peu
révisé nos prévisions entre septembre et
décembre et je crois pouvoir dire ce
matin que nous ne devrions avoir ni
récession même s'il y a un
ralentissement incontestable ni
installation durable de l'inflation même
si le travail de la politique monétaire
n'est pas
terminé alors pour préciser ce que je
viens de dire d'abord sur l'activité
nous menons vous le savez chaque mois
une enquête de conjoncture de terrain
auprès de 8500
entrepreneurs la dernière publiée début
janvier nous a conduit à remonter un peu
notre prévision de croissance sur le 4e
pr Dean dernier à + 02 % et à conforté
notre Pr ion pour 2024 à + 09 avant une
reprise progressive en 2025 et plus
encore en
2026 pour le dire autrement c'est une
croissance incontestablement ralentie
mais ça n'est pas un retournement de la
conjoncture depuis la rentrée de
l'automne le moteur de cette croissance
lui-même change un peu en cette année il
devient principalement la
consommation soutenue par la des
inflations qui entraînent une
augmentation des salaires réels
déduction faite de l'inflation et du
pouvoir d'achat alors j'en viens
justement à l'inflation qui a été qui
reste la première préoccupation des
Français nous avons observer une baisse
sensible tout au long de
2023 alors si je raisonne en IPCH et
nous savons que voilà le il y a deux
indices l'IPC national et l'IPC h
harmonisé européen euh le pic a été à
7,3 % en février dernier et on est
redescendu jusqu'à 4,1 en décembre c'est
encore trop bien
sûr euh notre prévision vous l'avez dit
monsieur le Président est à 2,5 % en
moyenne en 2024 et 1,8 % en moyenne en
2025 je vais surtout redire devant vous
ce matin un
engagement nous allons ramener
l'inflation à 2 % d'ici au plus tard
2025 la Banque de France a été la
première il y a un an à prendre cet
engagement publiquement je crois qu'il
suscitait un certain scepticisme à
l'époque il est aujourd'hui considéré
comme de plus en plus crédible ce qui
est une bonne nouvelle alors cette
confiance tient notamment au au fait que
la politique monétaire est efficace et
je suis conscient que le remède n'est
pas agréable vous y avez fait
allusion mais il
fonctionne l'inflation alors il y a
quelque fois des doutes sur le rôle de
la politique monétaire dans cette
désinflation je crois que la la
meilleure réponse à cette question c'est
de regarder parce que c'est vrai que la
baisse des prix la décélération des prix
de l'énergie a aidé mais la meilleure
réponse à cette interrogation c'est de
regarder l'évolution de l'inflation
sous-jacente hors alimentation qui elle
aussi a diminué de 4,7 % à son pic au
printemps dernier à 2,9 %
aujourd'hui mais cette confiance
n'exclut pas la vigilance bien sûr
notamment sur les conséquences des
conflits au Proche Orient et cette
confiance s'accompagne de patience sur
la politique
monétaire sauf surprise cette année sera
l'année de la baisse de nos taux
directeurs du coup vient souvent la
question de savoir quand exactement aura
lieu cette baisse je crois que cette
question est
prématuré parce que nous sommes guidés
non pas par un calendrier mais par les
données si vous me permettez une image
qui n'a rien à voir avec la politique
monétaire c'est la différence entre le
football et le
tennis de sport que nous pouvons bien
aimé le football est guidé par un temps
fixe et un calendrier fixe une partie de
90 minutes le tennis est guidé par des
sets à gagner et des étapes à passer de
ce point de vue là les décisions de
politique monétaire ressemblent plus à
un match de tennis nous sommes guidés
par les données je suis sûr que mon
image suscitera divers commentaires
réactions mais le le fond c'est que nous
sommes guidés par les données et des
données à observer il faut des pour
entamer la baisse des taux des
perspectives d' action ancré autour de 2
% solidement et durablement solidement
ça renvoie aux données effectives
observé et durablement ça renvoie aux
prévisions et aux données
prospectives dans cet environnement
conjoncturel qui n'est pas facile mais
qui est donc moins incertain et surtout
moins
inflationniste nous devons je crois
sortir un peu de la dictature de de
l'urgence économique et allonger L
horizon euh de notre politique
économique de notre débat économique et
ceci m'amène à trois défis structurel
que je voudrais évoquer rapidement
devant vous le désendettement public le
cap du plein emploi et le bon
financement de l'économie française et
européenne sur le désendettement public
euh ce défi est hélas connu notre
déficit public reste supérieur à ce
qu'il était précovid notre dette
publique à 110 % du PIB reste et restera
très supérieur au précovid de plus de 10
points de PIB et très supérieur à la
moyenne de la zone euro de plus de 20
points de
PIB il y a face à ce défi je crois deux
axes de
progrès d'abord je salue le
démantellement commencé des subventions
budgétaires face au chocs
énergétiqu ce démantellement doit aller
à son terme et il y a là je crois un
enseignement plus
général plutôt que ce qu'on pourrait
appeler des dépenses compensatrices
expost dont la France s fait une
spécialité la véritable clé de notre
réussite économique et tout ce qui
musclera en amont notre capacité
productive le deuxème axe de progrès
c'est je relève la l'adoption au Conseil
Ecofin du 20 décembre de nouvelles
règles budgétaires européennes ce qu'on
a appelé un cadre de moyen terme même si
elle reste hélas très
complexe l'essentiel est maintenant de
les appliquer et donc pour notre pays de
tenir ses engagements pluriannuels
jusqu'en
2027 je relève que ce serait très
nouveau et ce serait donc très
bienvenu le deuxè défic structurel que
j'ai évoqué c'est le cap du plein emploi
alors vous avez parlé monsieur le
Président du chaage qui est évidemment
un indicateur économique et social clé
il reste relativement bas malgré le
ralentissement économique à 7,4 %
aujourd'hui et je voudrais relever
positivement que la France a fait mieux
que ses voisins que tous ses voisins
depuis
2019 sur deux indicateurs l'augmentation
du nombre d'heures travaillé les
Français n'ont jamais autant travaillé
qu'aujourd'hui contrairement peut-être à
une image répandue et l'augmentation du
taux d'emploi qui est à plus de 68
%. nous ne sommes pour autant pas encore
au plein emploi nous en sommes même loin
à 5 % si on le défini à 5 % de chômage
et nous sommes encore loin du taux
d'emploi allemand qu'on peut estimer en
environ 72 % si on le corrige de l'effet
temps partiel en
Allemagne nous
pouvons je crois atteindre dans la
décennie cet objectif historique et
j'ass ceci parce que c'est à peu près
une correspondance économique un taux de
chômage à 5 % et un tau d'emploi autour
de 72 ce serait pour la première fois
depuis plus de 40 ans il me paraît
important que nous ne perdions pas ce
cap et que nous ne gâchions pas notre
chance ceci passe et nous pourrons y
revenir par un travail plus abondant
bien sûr mais aussi plus qualifié et
plus motivant y compris pour les
jeunes je termine si vous voulez bien
par le trisème défi que j'évoquais sur
le bon financement de l'économie
française et européenne et encore une
fois je ne prétends pas couvrir
l'ensemble des points dans mon propos
productif il y a bien sûr de gros
besoins d'investissement dans l'économie
française y compris dans l'immobilier
nous reviendrons sur le crédit
immobilier et en particulier il y a de
gros besoins de financement des deux
transformations qui sont en cours et qui
sont notre grand défi économique la
transformation numérique y compris
l'intelligence artificielle et la
transformation ou la transition
verte face à ces gros besoins nous avons
ont une ressource abondante c'est
l'épargne et l'épargne privée c'est vrai
à l'échelle française puis je viendrai
ensuite à l'échelle européenne le taux
d'éparne des Français se situe à la fin
du 3e trimestre à 17,7 % de le revenu
disponible brut c'est un peu inférieur à
l'Allemagne mais c'est supérieur à nos
autres voisins européens l'Espagne
l'Italie le Royaume-Uni et c'est très
supérieur aux États-Unis à 9 %.
euh le problème n'est donc pas tant le
montant que la composition de cette
épargne et je voudrais à cet égard
évoquer trois cercles si vous voulez
bien du plus restreint mais tout à fait
important ou plus large si je regarde
d'abord au sein de l'épargne liquide il
faut donner une vraie priorité à
l'épargne populaire c'est le sens des
propositions que j'ai été amené à faire
sur le livret d'éparne populaire et qui
ont été retenu par le le ministre un
taux fixé à 5 % soit très au-dessus de
la formule et encore plus au-dessus de
l'inflation à compté du 1er février
prochain un plafond remonté à 10000 € et
un objectif je le redis sur lequel les
banques se sont engagé de 12 millions et
demi de détenteurs du livret d'épares
populaire nous avons déjà beaucoup
progressé nous sommes à 10,7 millions
c'est plus de 3 millions de livret
supplémentaires en en 2 ans mais nous
devons aller plus loin je rappelle qu'il
y a entre 18 et 19 millions de Français
qui ont accès à ce produit qui est de
loin le plus
intéressant
pour
les les Français ayant moins de revenus
cet avantage n'existe d'ailleurs pas à
l'étranger je relève aussi sur l'épargne
réglementé que la stabilisation du taux
livré à 3 % a déjà permis une relance de
la production des prêts au logement
social de 9 % l'an dernier ça c'est le
premier cercle le 2e cercle c'est au
sein de l'épargne de taux euh en général
dont l'épargne liquide fait partie et
qui représente environ 60 % du
patrimoine financier des ménages donc
qui est très majoritaire il est
important de préserver aussi l'épargne
longue qui est l'assurance vie produit
très important en France
euh j'invite ici les assureurs à offrir
une rémunération suffisamment attractive
y compris sur le fond euro en utilisant
les réserves disponibles euh la
provision sur
bénéfice 3è cercle si je regarde
l'épagne dans son ensemble c'est le
développement souhaitable déplacement à
côté de l'épargne de Tau déplacement sur
fond propre alors là l'Europe dans son
ensemble et notamment la France est en
retard par rapport aux États-Unis les
chiffres sont assez frappants le les
placements euh des Français sous
diverses formes en produits de front
propre sont trois fois plus faibles
qu'aux États-Unis 93 % de notre PIB
contre 282 % aux
États-Unis pour le dire peut-être en
résumé les entreprises françaises les
entreprises européennes ne manquent pas
globalement de crédit elles manquent de
fonds propres ceci m'amène à la
dimension européenne peut-être pour
terminer sur le bon financement là aussi
l'épargne est une ressource abondante
disponible il y a un excédent d'épargne
en
2023 de 370 milliards de euros à
l'échelle européenne c'est-à-dire 2,6 %
de notre PIB et ceci renvoie un vieux
projet dont nous avons souvent parlé ici
mais qui je crois a connu une nouvelle
impulsion à la fin de l'année dernière
c'est l'union des marchés de capitaux
pour bien affecter l'ensemble de cette
ressource vers les besoins de transition
numérique et écologique dont j'ai parlé
euh Christine Lagarde en a parlé au mois
de novembre le ministre Bruno Lemire en
a parlé euh début janvier plus largement
j'appelle à ce que j'appellerai une
union de financement européenne verte et
numérique qui associe l'Union des
marchés de capitaux et l'Union bancaire
nous avons les besoins nous avons la
ressource privée il faut créer les
canaux de l'un vers l'autre et ceci fait
partie je crois ce sera ma dernière
remarque d'un réveil économique de
l'Europe dont nous avons
besoin face à la croissance américaine à
l'affirmation chinoise l'Europe ne doit
évidemment pas rester sur le côté du
terrain nous devons jouer résolument nos
atouts dans la compétition mondial il y
a cette mobilisation de l'éparne dont je
viens de parler il y a aussi la relance
du marché unique le marché unique ça
n'est pas qu'un glorieux héritage de
Jacques Delort ça reste un potentiel de
jouer plus résolument notre taille en
capacité d'attraction et de mobilisation
des des des entreprises nous pouvons
accroître encore significativement la
croissance
européenne puisque j'ai parlé d'Europe
je termine juste par une citation de
jean-met jean-met toujours un réservoir
citation mais celle-là me paraît d'un
grand bon sens et d'une grande actualité
à l'aube de 2024 ce qui est important ce
n'est ni d'être optimiste ni d'être
pessimiste c'est d'être déterminé
comptez en tout cas sur les équipes de
la Banque de France à leur place pour
l'êre à vos côtés
merci merci Monsieur le le
gouverneur donc comme vous l'avez dit
vous n'avez pas pu répondre à l'ensemble
du propos introductif mais à tous les
éléments par contre de de politique
macroéconomique en particulier euh très
clairement donc si vous le voulez bien
tout à l'heure dans une deuxème partie
on mélangera pas les sujets euh vous
pourrez revenir si vous le souhaitez sur
les questions liées à l'euronumérique
c'est une question disons euh euh plus
ponctuelle euh en cours si je puis dire
mais qui nous intéresse également parce
qu'elle commence à être euh bien sur le
et et à bal 3 aussi et et à bal 3
également qui est
une toutes deux deux questions de nature
bancaire on peut dire en tout cas autour
de la question question des banques donc
je vous propose de les laisser un peu
sur la fin effectivement de nos propos
je donne tout d'abord la parole au
rapporteur général et puis ne vous
inquiétez pas vous avez déjà 10
questions de nos
collègues ça ne fait que commencer
monsieur rapporteur général merci
monsieur le Président merci Monsieur
gouverneur et à mon tour de vous
souhaiter ainsi qu'à vos équipes mes
meilleurs
vœux je
voudrais croire à la citation vous avez
emprunté un ganmoné sur ni pessimiste ni
optimistme mais déterminé en tournant la
page de 2023 le Sénat dans son travail
budgétaire s'est montré déterminé mais
pour autant encore faut-il que cette
détermination puisse trouver une
traduction et pour tout dire au regard
de la responsabilité qui est la vôtre je
dois dire que on s'est plutôt heurté à
un mur sur les travaux qui ont été
commis et sur les multiples propositions
qui avait pour but de faire bouger notre
économie dans le bon sens je vais
revenir sur très rapidement sur
quelquesuns des aspects que vous avez
évoqué notamment sur la politique
monétaire peut-on dire aujourd'hui que
vous avez expliqué qu'elle était
efficace mais
douloureuse donc pensez-vous qu'elle
durcissement produit ses effets et que
donc on devrait rentrer dans une période
je dirais de plus grande stabilité et de
moindre douleur
euh si je pose cette question c'est
parce qu'en fait on s'aperçois que dans
le le lien entre les prévisions de
croissance et le resserement de la
politique monétaire notamment pour 2024
euh je note quand même que sur la
prévision de croissance vous faites une
prévision de croissance à 0,9 là où le
gouvernement l'a fait à 144 c'est un
écart qui me paraît substantiel
et au regard de je dirais de de des
délais de transmission à l'économie de
la politique monétaire on peut se poser
des questions puisque par exemple des
études récentes montrent qu'à la suite
d'une hausse des taux directeurs de 100
points de base le PIB réel diminue en
moyenne au cours des de trimestre
suivant de 03 % et que les effets
perdurent jusqu'au 8e trimestre c'était
pas tout à fait ce qu'on disait il y a
une dizaine d'années puisque en gros on
pensait que ça allait entre 25 et 50
mois autre sujet
sur finalement ça fait un peu écho à ce
que j'ai dit au départ sur une mener une
politique budgétaire
responsable quel quel regard portez-vous
sur l'accord qui est est intervenu
récemment entre les États-membres sur le
pacte de stabilité et de croissance on
était plutôt sur dans les travaux de la
commission de la différenciation et on
s'aperçoit que sous la pression
allemande on est plutôt arrivé sous une
forme comment dirais-je d'alignement et
d'uniformité donc quel est comment
dirais-je quel est votre
appréciation sur ces nouvelles règles
qui vont être mises en place alors j'ai
bien entendu
il faut non seulement les mettre en
place mais les respecter ce qui ne
sa'est jamais avez-vous sous-entendu
pour ne pas dire dit dans votre propos
ce qui ne manque pas d'ailleurs de de là
aussi de m'interpeller et puis je
voudrais revenir enfin sur le sujet du
plein
emploi finalement vous évoquez le fait
qu'on a des indicateurs intéressants
alors je les prends les deux indicateurs
intéressants mais je constate que
simultanément on est très en retard sur
la
productivité et que on est surtout sous
on est en porte à faau avec l'évolution
de la déprise
démographique celle-ci je suis désolé
elle a un effet mécanique et donc quel
de votre point de vue comment est-ce que
ça peut se traduire est-ce que ça veut
dire aussi qu'il faudrait en musclant
l'appareil produit productif et la
production industrielle recourir
davantage et à de la main d'œuvre si on
l'a pas
suffisamment d'immigration et également
à de la
robotisation puisque notamment dans le
secteur de l'automobile si on veut aller
très
vite être performant aujourd'hui il faut
pouvoir faire du travail de 38 et sur
l'année complète mais c'est des sujets
qui doivent être portés dans le débat
public dans le même temps que vous
l'avez dit meilleure qualification ce
qui veut dire un meilleur appareil de
formation mais ce que j'appelle moi de
la formation comment dirais-je
opérationnel et pas ce que j'appellerais
plus occupationnel subventionné à grand
renfor d'argent public et là me
semble-t-il est un c'est un enjeu pour
la France mais vous l'avez dit c'est un
enjeu jeu européen et je terminerai par
là parce que effectivement je pense que
que ce soit pour Arian espace mais et je
dis ça en regardant le le le président
de la commission des finances enfin je
préfère aujourd'hui et on devrait avoir
une fierté collective française
européenne au côté derrière abus quand
on regarde dans la compétition mondiale
ce que le géant
américain en terme d'aviation
aujourd'hui rencontre comme difficulté
je ne dis pas qu'il faut s'en réjouir
mais quand l'Europe gagne et fait gagner
les pays membres c'est ça doit être
porté
haut merci monsieur le rapporteur
général donc des des questions assez
large Monsieur le Gouverneur est-ce que
vous souhaitez y apporter peut-être
quelques éléments
d'éclairage euh je peux donner quelques
éléments et peut-être revenir tout de
suite sur la question bal 3 et du crédit
je pense qu'on on reviendra sur
l'euronumérique
ensuite
euh alors
sur le propos du du rapporteur général
je crois que nous partageons la
détermination j'avoue que dans le les
mots que vous avez employé le mot mur
m'a un peu frappé Toutant que j'ai
compris qu'il s'appliquait à la Banque
de France bon alors dans ce caslà ah ben
voilà je rappelle que la Banque de
France est indépendante mais ça veut pas
dire que la Banque de France est
irréprochable donc si nous pouvons faire
encore mieux dans le travail que le
Sénat n nous serons heureux de le faire
sur la politique monétaire
euh
alors je suis conscient encore une fois
qu'il est plus agréable d'avoir des taux
très bas que les taux relativement
élevés que nous avons eu euh mais je
crois que c'était absolument nécessaire
quand notre boussole c'est l'inflation
et je crois que c'est une boussole qui
est totalement légitime parce que c'est
la première préoccupation des Français
ça l'a été depuis 2 ans et cela le reste
aujourd'hui
donc il est prioritaire de vaincre
l'inflation et c'est prioritaire aussi
pour la croissance dans la durée parce
que l'inflation trop élevée mange le
pouvoir d'achat et donc la consommation
et peut-être de façon plus
insidieuse mange la confiance et donc
notre capacité à nous projeter dans
l'avenir et à
investir alors quand la Banque Centrale
Européenne a pu mener des politiques de
taux très bas elle l'a fait
j'ajouterai même quand elle a dû mener
des politiques de taux très bas c'était
le cas jusqu'en 2021 puisque nous avions
une inflation très basse voire une
menace de déflation au moment du covid
je crois qu'on a pu éviter la déflation
mais souvenez-vous du du débat qui a
existé fin début 2020 fin 2021 début
2022 le reproche était plutôt inverse
que la banque centrale avait des taux
trop bas et qu'elle tardait trop à à à
monter je ne crois pas que nous ayons
tarder on pourrait revenir sur le débat
mais il faut mener une politique
monétaire en fonction de cette boussole
prioritaire qui est l'inflation c'est
notre boussole je dirais euh juridique
puisque c'est le traité les statuts de
la Banque centrale mais c'est aussi une
boussole économique et je crois
politique
fondée alors il ne faut pas non plus la
mener à l'excès ou euh trop trop
longtemps vous avez donné monsieur le
rapporteur général des chiffres sur
l'effet sur la
croissance de la politique monétaire il
y a beaucoup d'estimations en la matière
je ne récuse pas forcément celle-là je
ne crois pas non plus que ces effets
soient plus forts que dans le passé mais
je serais tout prêt à ce que nous
puissions partager avec la commission
des finances un certain nombre
d'estimations en la matière ce que je
voudrais
noter c'est que la politique monétaire
agit aussi à travers les
anticipations canal des des
anticipations il me semble que c'est la
principale différence avec les années
1970 le choc énergétique que nous avons
subi le choc de matières premières en
deux temps hein fin 2021 avec la reprise
covid et puis début 2022 avec
malheureusement l'invasion de l'Ukraine
ressemble pas mal au choc des années 70
mais ces effets spontanés étaient les
mêmes je crois que la réaction de
politique monétaire a été assez
différente que euh
une des raisons qui explique je crois le
le succès aujourd'hui à ce stade de la
désinflation c'est que les entreprises
les ménages les marchés financiers
l'ensemble des acteurs économiques sont
restés convaincus que l'inflation
reviendrait vers 2 % parce que la banque
centrale agirait c'est ça qu'on appelle
le canal des anticipations et je crois
que c'est aujourd'hui un succès
important de la politique monétaire je
relève au passage que c'est taux à 4 %
hein le le le taux t directeur de la
Banque centrale est un taux qui est
nettement moins élevé qu'aux États-Unis
à 5 et demi et qui est beaucoup moins
élevé que le niveau auquel les taux
d'intérêt avaient dû monter dans les
années 70 donc le fait d'agir tôt a
permis d'agir moins fort et il y aura
comme je le disais baisse des taux cette
année même si j'ai été prudent et et
patient sur son
calendrier voilà mais soyez assurés que
nous sommes déterminés par cet objectif
d'inflation à 2 % et qu'il s'agit pas de
faire un excès de de resserrement ou de
ou de rigueur monétaire alors sur la
politique budgétaire je dirais que ma
situation est plutôt plus confortable
parce que ça ça ne relève pas de la
Banque centrale et je crois que nous
partageons monsieur le rapporteur
général les souhaits vraiment d'un
désendettement de la France vous avez
posé la question des règles issues de
l'accord européen du 20 décembre et
est-ce qu'il s'agit de trop d'uniformité
ou d'alignement par rapport à
l'Allemagne je ne crois pas je pense
qu'un certain nombre de chiffres ont été
réintroduits ou de règles vous savez
c'est ce fameux débat entre les règles
chiffré et le jugement bon je vais dire
avec je pense un certain pragmatiste
qu'il faut les deux parce que si on
renvoie uniquement au jugement
l'expérience prouve qu'il y a toujours
des bonnes raisons de ne pas faire
l'ajustement
budgétaire si on renvoie uniquement aux
règles on oublie la divers des
circonstances donc je crois qu'il
fallait aussi des des règles chiffrées
si j'ai un
regret je l'ai dit mais je va peut-être
un peu le préciser c'est leur
complexité et la négociation a conduit à
des règles sont plus complexes que la
proposition initiale de la commission
pour citer un exemple la proposition de
la Commission reposait beaucoup sur
l'idée d'une norme de dépense et je
crois que c'est une bonne chose parce
que ça c'est un critère que tout le
monde peut comprendre partager discuter
et réapparu la notion de solld de
structure urelle qui est une notion
beaucoup plus subtile
complexe voire discutable sur le plan
sur le plan des chiffres voilà donc ça
n'est pas parfait mais je crois que ça
au moins le mérite d'exister et comme
vous l'avez dit l'essentiel va être
l'application sur le plein emploi oui la
démographie joue elle joue heureusement
pour l'instant un peu moins en France
qu'ailleurs je rappelle ces seuils
l'Allemagne dès cetten va voir sa
population active diminuer la France
devrait voir sa population active
diminuer à peu près autour de 2030 selon
selon les les
estimations alors certaines des pistes
que vous avez évoqué l'immigration sur
des métiers en tension la robotisation
sont bien sûr
nécessaires je je veux pas du tout
opposer les solutions je crois que nous
devons les ajouter je soulligne
simplement que la question de la
formation de la qualification reste
absolument clé ce paradoxe insupportable
en France que nous ayons encore plus de
2 millions de chômeurs des centaines de
milliers de jeunes au chômage et en même
temps 41 % des entreprises qui font état
de difficultés de recrutement c'est la
double peine c'est un paradoxe
économique et surtout social
insoutenable donc l'enjeu d'une
formation professionnelle qui soit
effectivement la plus opérationnelle
possible de poursuivre le succès de
l'apprentissage et bien sûr de la
réforme de l'école est absolument clé
peut-être dernière remarque à ce propos
mais je vais arriver dans un terrain peu
chiffré et et assez qualitatif j'ai
ajouté dans mon propos introductif le le
fait d'avoir un travail qui soit plus
motivant cette question de la motivation
au travail monte beaucoup de la part des
chefs d'entreprise de la part des jeunes
dans le débat social et pas seulement en
France et ça recouvre des choses sur le
sens au travail sur le télétravail sur
l'autonomie dont on dispose je crois que
le travail de demain doit être différent
du travail d'hier en qualification il
doit être plus qualifié mais aussi en
sens en organisation et ça me paraît
plutôt une bonne chose c'est un effort
qui incombe d'ailleurs aussi aux
entreprises mais le point sur lequel
j'insiste c'est que nous avons une
chance historique d'atteindre l'objectif
du plein emploi je suis conscient qu'il
y a un débat sur le calendrier j'ai dit
dans la décennie ça dépendra aussi du
cycle économique ne manquons pas cette
chance ça serait la première fois depuis
plus de 40 ans sur bal 3 monsieur le
Président pour traiter une de vos
question j'entends comme vous un certain
nombre d'interrogations des banques
françaises nous avons eu parfois
l'occasion d'en parler ici je crois que
bal 3 est un bon équilibre et qu'il faut
maintenant le mettre en œuvre bal 3 est
un avantage européen contrairement ce
qu'on a parfois dit je rappelle qu'au
moment de la crise bancaire du mois de
mars en Californie et en
Suisse on a eu l'occasion d'entendre et
ça me paraissait très bienvenu un
consensus de tous y compris les banques
françaises en disant nous sommes
protégés de la crise grâce à balle 3
c'était vrai ça s'est vérifié et donc
quand la menace de la crise s'éloigne il
faut pas revenir en disant ah mais les
règles de ball 3 sont trop
contraignantes et vont empêcher la
distribution du crédit non elles
n'empêcheront pas la distribution du
crédit immobilier elles n'empêcheront
pas la distribution du crédit aux
entreprises et aux PME je crois que
c'est plutôt un avantage européen je
souhaite ardemment d'ailleurs que les
propositions qui ont été faites par la
Fédérale réserve américaine soi
transcrite en réalité parce que là il y
a un retard
américain et le lobby bancaire américain
est extrêmement actif aujourd'hui pour
combattre les propositions de la
Fédérale réserve il y a un retard
américain qui s'est payé au mois de mars
par la crise bancaire comme vous le
savez silicon Valé banque et d'autres
banques n'étaient pas soumises aux
règles de bal 3 ça c'est'est
vu donc je m'engage vraiment vis-à-vis
de votre commission des finances sur le
fait que ça n'empêchera pas la capacité
des banques à bien financer l'économie
française merci Monsieur le Gouverneur
pour ses premières réponses Didier
rambau puis Michel canbé merci Président
Monsieur le
Gouverneur je lis régulièrement vos vos
interviews vos prises de position et et
vous avez indiqué récemment je vous cite
la période qui s'ouvre sera une période
d'argent au juste prix et non une
période d'argent gratuit et facile alors
selon vous qu'est- ce que ça veut dire
exactement une période d'argent au au
juste prix deuxième question qui
concerne les les l'augmentation du
nombre de dossiers de surendettement on
a observé ces dernières années une forte
baisse effectivement
de de dossier déposés et là maintenant
ça repart une augmentation de de 8 % du
nombre de dossiers de surentêement
déposés auprès de la Banque de France
donc quelle explication vous avez alors
que je vous cite vous avez tout à
l'heure vous avez vous avez dit on n
jamais autant travaillé en France donc-
quels sont les les quel est votre regard
particulier sur cette augmentation du
nombre de dossiers de ce rendettement et
enfin effectivement je résiste pas à
vous poser la question sur le le tau
directeur de la Banque centrale
européenne euh je fais un lien avec le
secteur du logement hein on va vers une
catastrophe probablement on a tous des
messages d'alerte sur la la la
construction euh et là alors vous avez
skquissé aussi une baisse probable de du
de ce tau directeur mais est-ce qu'on
peut avoir peut-être un calendrier plus
précis euh est-ce que vous êtes en
capacité de nous le dire parce que je
pense qu'on a besoin d'avoir les acteurs
de la construction ont besoin d'avoir un
signe dans les prochaines semaines à ce
sujet là merci merci Didier Michel canev
puis MarieClaire
carerg merci monsur le gouverneur de vos
propos optimiste sur les objectifs
vis-à-vis de l'inflation je je partage
les trois défis que vous venez d'évoquer
d'une part sur la question du
désentêement public et je voulais savoir
à cet égard si le niveau de
l'endettement public pesa sur les
comptes propres de la banque de France
je partage aussi bien entendu le défi
sur l'emploi effectivement le taux de
chômage demeure une préoccupation dans
notre pays mais on voit dans certains
territoires que l'on peut aller beaucoup
mieux je pense au territoire de Vitré ou
en Vendé où on voie un taux de chômage
autour de 3 3 et5i % ça montre que l'on
peut certainement aller plus loin sur
les territoires et puis euh euh je
partage aussi les questions relatifes
relatives à l'Invest
et comme Didier rambau vient de
l'évoquer à l'instant nous pouvons
exprimer néanmoins de très vives
inquiétudes sur la question du logement
on voit bien la production est très
clairement en baisse pour ce qui
concerne les établissements
bancaires on voit des difficulté à
l'accès au logement et je dirais que
c'est même le logement locatif qui est
empané je pense que parmi les critères
que le Haut Conseil pour la stabilité
financière a mise en œuvre a édicté pour
les banques
je pense que il y a pas suffisamment de
de marge de manœuvre en particulier pour
ceux qui veulent faire du locatif car
nous manquons de logement locatif qui
est un élément essentiel pour la
mobilité et donc pour l'accès à l'emploi
sur notre pays et donc le critère de
d'introduire l'ensemble des des charges
de remboursement à un niveau maximal de
35 % des revenus et pénalisant pour ceux
qui veulent faire du locatif en
complément et qui veulent apporter des
réponses
à ceux de nos concitoyens qui ont besoin
de pouvoir se loger près de leur travail
et là il y a sans doute des des choses à
faire tout comme laisser un tout petit
peu plus de latitude aux banques parce
que la les latitudes de 20 % sur les
Primot excédent ou ou autres dossier les
banques nous disent clairement que c'est
particulièrement difficile pour ell de
pouvoir les appliquer on peut avoir des
disponibilités en novembre et pas les
avoir en décembre pour le même type de
dossier par exemple
et on voit bien que bon nombre de nos
concitoyens souffrent de refus de de de
prêt de de de prêt pour l'immobilier
pour investir dans l'immobilier alors
même qu'ils ont des apports financiers
tout à fait importants et cel une
préoccupation puis dernier point sur la
question de du droit au compte et de
l'inclusion bancaire he puisque la la
Cour des comptes avait évoqué je dirais
la difficulté pour les banques de
respecter ce droit au compte beaucoup le
font mais beaucoup ne le font pas non
plus dans l'observatoire deinclusion
bancaire la banque de France en 2022
avait observé dans son enquête les mêmes
analyse bon le décret de de 2022 a
maintenant donne l'obligation au banque
de signaler à la à la Banque de France
les euh comment dirais-je les les les
anomalies observées euh est-ce que vous
avez observé Monsieur le Gouverneur que
les pratiques des banques se sont
améliorées sur le droit au compte et sur
euh euh les explicitations pour ceux qui
se voient opposer à un
refus merci Michel MarieClaire carerg
puis Hervé
Maé merci monsieur le Président très
brièvement une question qui rejoint
celle qui a été posée par Didier rambau
sur sur l'augmentation du du nombre de
recours procédure de surendettement pour
savoir et qui tronche avec les les
évolutions de long terme pour savoir si
euh vous estim mais que ça s'explique
avant tout par par le fait qu'on était
arrivé à une sorte de plancher et que
donc voilà c'est où est-ce que vous
voyez d'autres
explication et par ailleurs si je peux
me permettre nuancer un peu votre
appréciation si positive sur la
situation et
l'évolution sur le marché du travail sur
sur l'emploi d'abord on a un taux de
chômage qui est quand même en légère
augmentation et qui est à + 15 par
rapport à la zone euro et + 25 par
rapport à l'UE d'autre part euh le
l'expression on n'a jamais autant
travailler en France elle s'explique
quand même et donc l'augmentation du
taux d'emploi qui le CAN corollaire ben
s'explique quand
même un peu par l'explosion de
l'apprentissage donc enfin c'est c'est
un peu à à relativiser et enfin bien
qu'on est encore un taux de chômage
supérieur supérieur aux autres et donc
un nombre de salariés peut qualifier un
emploi euh qui est proportionnellement
plus faible que d'autres on se distingue
pas par un niveau de la productivité qui
serait qui serait flambant et ça il me
semble que c'est quand même assez
inquiéton à moyen terme je vous
remercie merci MarieClaire Hervé Moré
puis Marc
laminii merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Gouverneur je voudrais vous
poser deux questions la première sur la
cryptomonnaiee et la seconde sur la
fraude au virement sur la cryptoonnaie
vous vous souvenez que le Parlement
l'Inti notre commission a renforcé le
dispositif et qu'il y a depuis le 1er
janvier un système d'enregistrement
renforcé qui a été mis en place la Cour
des comptes a émis des inquiétudes sur
le fait que cette ce renforcement des
règles nationales et européennes allait
peut-être mettre en difficulté la MF et
et la CPR en terme de de charge de
travail je voulais avoir votre sentiment
là-dessus par ailleurs il reste je crois
90 entreprises qui vont rester sous le
régime de l'enregistrement simple
jusqu'à ce que le l'agrément entre en en
application pour elle c'est-à-dire en en
2026 en juin 2026 et toujours sur ce
sujet vous avez appelé à la mise en
place d'un Mik 2 je crois que des
réunions ont déjà eu lieu sur ce sujet
est-ce que vous pourriez nous en dire un
petit peu plus deuxème sujet c'est la
question de la fraude au virement la
Banque de France l'a évalué au premier
semestre 2022 à 1/4 des sommes
extorquées je pense que depuis le
premier semestre 2022 les choses se sont
aggravées euh alors pour que tous mes
collègues sachent de quoi je veux parler
le système est est très simple vous
recevez une facture de d'une entreprise
à qui vous devez de l'argent j'en parle
malheureusement toute connaissance de
cause que j'en ai été victime vous
recevez une facture et le lendemain vous
recevez de la même boîte mail un une
information disant j'ai changé de compte
voilà mon nouveau RIB et comme ça vient
de la même boîte mail vous ne vous
méfiez pas euh je comme je l'ai dit j'en
ai été victime mais je sais qu'un
certain nombre d'entreprises on ont été
victimes parfois pour des sommes de
plusieurs millions même dizaines de
millions donc je voulais savoir si il y
avait des mesures qui étaient envisagées
pour essayer de de remédier à cette
fraude qui est évidemment très difficile
à contourner comp tenu de de de de de sa
dimension numérique et piratage
informatique et puis surtout je voudrais
savoir ce qui est envisagé pour la
protection du consommateur parce
qu'aujourd'hui il semblerait que
contrairement à la fraude aux cartes
bancaire les banques n'aient aucune
obligation en la matière de de rembours
des des victimes donc je voulais savoir
si une réflexion était en cours sur le
sujet je vous remercie
mercib Marc Lamini puis sili merci
monsieur le Président merci beaucoup
merci Monsieur le le gouverneur de de
votre exposé particulièrement toujours
complet alors je reviens un peu sur une
question que m'était permis de de vous
poser il y y a quelques
temps pour concernant le département des
ardenes que je représente et le maillage
du territoire et à l'époque vous avvez a
répondu vous étiez très attaché à la
présence de la Banque de France je
dirais sur les territoires on représente
cert un petit département moins de
300000 habitants mais aussi avec des
entreprises et je crois que c'est
important d'avoir des relais des bons
interlocuteurs j'irais sur le terrain et
alors en ce qui concerne
l'organisation de de la Banque de France
est-ce que vous pérénisez un petit peu
le les moyens humains sur sur le terrain
et en proximité en proximité et le lien
aussi avec beaucoup le monde économique
puis une question peut-être qu'on qu'on
pourrait aborder et c'est aussi pour les
particuliers pour les ménages qu'en
est-il un petit peu des l'évolution des
surendettements parce que bon
malheureusement j' dirais il y a des
factures notamment électricité ou aut
chauffage ou autre et puis il y a quand
même
malheureusement beaucoup de personnes en
situation difficile donc voilà un petit
peu c'était mes modestes questions je
vous remercie beaucoup merci Marc Sylvie
vermeiller puis Antoine Lefèvre merci
monsieur le Président merci à vous
Monsieur le Gouverneur pour votre
présentation j'aurais une question
principale qui concerne l'épargne des
Français vous avez dit que elle
s'élevait à 17,7 % du revenu disponible
brut que c'était un peu moins qu'en
Allemagne mais que c'était bien
supérieur euh à à l'épargne aux
États-Unis est-ce qu'on s'assure bien
que cette épargne ce sont les banques
françaises qui la Capte et est-ce qu'on
a moyen de enfin est-ce qu'on a des
dispositifs justement pour encourager
cela et éviter la fuite vers des banques
étrangères type JP Morgan ou autres
voilà et je suis un peu inquiète sur cet
aspect là et
l'évolution des parts de marché des des
banques étrangères et puis juste en
ement de ce que Hervé Moret vient vient
de dire est-ce que justement
l'intelligence
artificielle participe à à la lutte
contre la fraude bancaire qui est
effectivement très inquiétante
merci merci Sylvie Antoine Lefèvre puis
Christine Lavarde merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Gouverneur alors
Didier rambau tout à l'heure a déjà
évoqué le dossier du du surendettement
l'augmentation de 8 % en
2023 un contexte que que nous
connaissons et une contraction du du
budget des ménages euh dans les outils
de dernier recours que que propose la
Banque de France dans les cas grave de
surendettement il y a la possibilité de
d'effacer la la totalité de la dette
alors bien sûr souvent les créances sont
détenus par des acteurs institutionnels
privés
euh et et donc pour ceci c'est effec qui
représente 3 à 4 % des effacements euh
il y a aussi des ménages qui sont en en
difficulté financière alors ma question
c'est de savoir
si dans ce cadre précis des des
particuliers est-ce qu'il y a des des
propositions de compensation financière
malgré tout quel dispositif
disposez-vous dans ces procédures
d'effacement vis-à-vis des des
particuliers
qui qui sont dans dans ces difficultés
merci merci Antoine Christine lavade
puis Jeanrond
Hugonet oui merci monsieur le Président
alors dans le
rapport de France stratégie sur la la le
financement de la transition écologique
il avait un sous-rapport compétitivité
qui a traité partiellement de la
question de l'accès aux ressources
financières et dans cette partie du
rapport il y a une seule hypothèse qui
est traitée qui est celle de
l'introduction d'une taxe carbone aux
frontières avec ou pas l'accompagnement
d'une politique monétaire et pour autant
euh il me semble qu'il y a d'autres
pistes
d'évolution qui existe et notamment
toutes celles qui sont portées par le
réseau des Banques Centrales engagées
pour pour la finances vertes auxquell
appartient la Banque de France et il y a
une idée qui me semble intéressante et
d'ailleurs le président de la République
je crois en la glisse en filigram dans
une de ces derni dernières tribunes
c'est l'introduction d'un taux
différencié pour les actifs verts et les
actifs bruns taux qui pourrait notamment
trouver à sa appliqué pour toutes les
actions de rénovation énergétique si
j'entends qu'il était compliqué d'avoir
une
politique de ce type tant qu'on était
dans un contexte inflationniste à partir
du moment où effectivement comme vous
l'avez indiqué dans votre propos
liminaire on s'oriente plutôt vers une
diminution des des taux directeurs cette
distinction pourrait trouver à s'opérer
est-ce que c'est des choses que la
Banque de France va
pousser merci Christine Jeanron Hugonet
puis Thierry kzic merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le le gouverneur nous
sortons de l'examen du projet de loi de
finances 2024 et nous avons pu constater
l'extrême
dégradation des comptes publics dans
notre pays
comment quand on a connaissance de de
cela comment
analysez-vous l'évolution positive et
constante d'un indicateur qui est peu
employé qui s'appelle le patrimoine
économique
national
merci Jean
Raymond Thierry Cosic puis Guilen sen
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Gouverneur on le sait la variation des
taux d'intérêt une influence directe sur
le renchissement des crédits et sur la
baisse de la capacité
d'achat notamment dans ce contexte
l'application des mesures relatives à
l'octroit d'un crédit imposé par le Haut
Conseil de stabilité financière aux
banques accroit les difficultés d'accès
au financement c'est é évoqué tout à
l'heure notamment la dérogation
2023 qui proposait que 20 % des nouveaux
prêts accordés peuvent déroger aux
normes contraignante de ces mesures donc
avec une limitation à 25 ans de la durée
maximale des crédits à l'habitat à 35 %
le taux d'effort maximum pesant sur les
emprunteurs pour les primau accidents et
les particuliers sans détant à acquérir
le leur résidence principale les refus
près se multiplie pour des raisons
parfois absurdes à tout le moins
curieuses
les exemples se multiplient j'ai eu un
échange dernièrement avec un promoteur
qui me disait que sur sur 10 compromis
de vente il y avait 10 refus de prêt je
vais vous citer une situation preuve
s'il en fallait une personne habitant à
Paris souhaitant acheter un appartement
au Man en S à 200000 € et disposant d'un
apport de 80000 € s'est vu refuser un
prêt sous prétexte qu'il ne serait pas
propriétaire de sa résidence principale
en effet parce que ce financement risque
aurait en effet bloqué un financement
ultérieur pour l'acquisition de sa
propre résidence principale donc je
voulais savoir Monsieur le Gouverneur
quel était le le regard al non pas porté
sur sur cette situation précise mais
quel est le regard de de la Banque de
France sur sur cette situation qui qui
est
rencontrée sur sur l'accès sur l'accès
au financement au logement mais c'est
aussi la difficulté qu'elle va entraîner
sur le sur le sur le secteur du bâtiment
voir s'il y a des il y a des mesures qui
sont qui sont envisagé pour assouplir
l'ensemble de de ces critères
d'accès merci thier g puis Isabelle
Brequet
oui merci monsieur le Président
alors madame Lavarde a évoqué
effectivement la question des taux des
taux différenciés je voulais savoir si
la Banque de France effectivement est en
capacité de pouvoir les mettre en œuvre
avec une majorationif des taux pour les
investissements bruns bien évidemment et
une minoration pour les investissements
verts l'autre l'autre question ce serait
de savoir est-ce que nous pouvons
aujourd'hui connaître l'horizon temporel
d'une mise en place d'un taux d'intérêt
vert et et le troisième point est qu'il
y a un enjeu d'adaptation du système
financier au risque liés au dérèglement
climatiqu moi je pensais que d'ailleurs
ça allait être un défi que vous alliez
mentionner en fait vous vous ne
mentionnez le le la transition verte que
que dans le cadre du Défi bon
fonctionnement de l'économie française
euh le risque financier systémique hein
lié à l'urgence climatique et et et au
dérèglement climatique semble bien
évidemment un vrai enjeu et et comment
aujourd'hui la Banque de France
travaille-t-elle sur les scénarios euh
climatiques et la résilience du système
financier
français merci giseline Isabelle briquet
qui
conclut merci monsieur le président euh
Monsieur le Gouverneur selon une étude
du FMI les les banques centrales de la
zone euro devraient enregistrer des des
pertes de 55 milliards d'euros entre
2023 et et 2024 soit l'équivalent de 0,5
% du un PIB de la zone ces pertes sont
la conséquence de l'importance des des
bilans des banques centrales alors que
les taux d'intérêts sont
simultanément élevés la la Bundesbank et
la banque de de France devrait
enregistrer des pertes
respectivement de respectivement 26
milliards d'euros et 17 milliards
d'euros en 2023 de même la Réserve
fédérale américaine devrait enregistrer
des pertes de 100 milliards de dollars
cette année qui pourit culminer environ
200 milliards en en 2000 de dollars en
2025 si de telles pertes étaient
maintentenu pendant une longue période
des questions se poseraient quant à la
capacité des banques centrales a
financer leurs propres activités c'est
pourquoi je souhaiterais avoir votre
avis sur ces pertes et sur leurs
conséquences je vous
remerci merci
Isabelle Monsieur le Gouverneur euh
monsieur le Président je vous d'abord
saluer la qualité et la richesse des
questions je sais pas être trop long
mais euh c'est presque toujours le cas
quand je viens à la commission des
finances mais ça me frappe
particulièrement alors je vais prendre
peut-être les questions dans l'ordre et
je n'oublierai pas l'euro numérique à la
fin puisque
euh monsieur rambau merci d'avoir lu mes
propos sur l'argent au juste prix trouve
je les ai tenu hier en plus pour tout
vous dire j'étais à Davos où j'essayais
de voilà expliquer un peu aussi ce que
la France faisait euh ce que j'ai voulu
dire par là c'est que il y a eu une
période et j'y faisais allusion tout à
l'heure en réponse au rapporteur général
mettons entre 2015 et 2022 où les taux
d'intérêt étaient extrêmement bas et je
crois que c'était justifié par cette
boussole qu l'inflation et le fait de
combattre le risque de déflation et
quand nous pouvons soutenir l'activité
économique sans prendre de risque
inflationniste nous le faisons
euh donc à l'époque les taux réels
c'est-à-dire déduction faite de
l'inflation était clairement négatif je
crois qu'un argent au juste prix alors
ça ne se voulait pas une annonce sur le
niveau des taux d'intérêt cette année ou
à la fin de l'année mais à moyen terme
un argent au juste prix c'est en moyenne
des taux d'intérêt réels qui sont plutôt
à l'équilibre à zéro
euh et si vous ajoutez une inflation à 2
% en moyenne ça fait des taux nominaux
encore une fois pour les taux de la
Banque centrale qui sont en moyenne
autour de 2 %. alors ça varie au long du
cycle quand il y a des monace
inflationniste faut être un peu
au-dessus quand il y a en sens inverse
une inflation qui peut être insuffisante
faut être un peu en dessous mais c'est
ça le repère que j'ai voulu donner le
nouveau normal demain une fois sorti de
cet épisode inflationniste hein après
2025 ne sera pas le retour à une
situation qui était assez exceptionnelle
dans l'autre sens entre 2015 et et 2022
sur les dossiers de surendettement vous
avez été nombreux à poser la question et
effectivement nous avons constaté sur
2023 une hausse de 8 % du nombre de
dossiers de surendettement alors je vais
être prudent sur l'interprétation de ce
chiffres et nous partageons un certain
nombre des questions que vous avez posé
pourquoi parce que les effets covid
restent assez forts euh sur les trois
dernières années nous avions observé
paradoxalement une baisse forte du
nombre de dossiers de surendettement en
2020 2021 et là il y a une certaine
correction de tendance nous continuons à
regarder par rapport à 2019 par rapport
à précovid et là le nombre de dossiers
en 2023 est en baisse de 15 % par
rapport au précovid voilà donc je ne
surinterpréterai pas à ce stade le plus
su nous restons cependant très attentif
et si la tendance devait se confirmer
avec des explications tenant à la
situation économique et sociale mais je
vais être honnête nous ne les avons pas
aujourd'hui ce que je peux dire c'est
que les équipes de la bangue de France
sont évidemment totalement mobilisé avec
les points conseil budget pour pour
traiter ces situations le le mieux
possible vous avez enfin posé beaucoup
d'autres sénateurs l'ont fait après vous
la question du logement alors là je vaux
être un petit peu plus long et je veux
d'abord peut-être marquer deux
précautions si vous voulez bien et puis
ensuite donner un certain nombre de
points d'accord et de perspective les
deux précautions c'est que je crois que
comparer le niveau des prêts immobiliers
aujourd'hui qui est autour de 9
milliards d'euros pour les crédits
nouveaux chaque mois
au montant qu'on a connu en 2021 ou
début 2022 qui était au-delà de 20
milliards ça ça n'est pas la bonne
référence le 9 milliards est un souci
hein je vais y revenir après mais le
plus de 20 milliards était totalement
exceptionnel parce qu'il correspondait à
une période de taux ultra bas souv v le
crédit immobilier était entre 1 et 1 et
demi % à l'époque les ménages français
ont été parfaitement rationnels ils sont
venus tirer des crédits immobilier très
fortement comme en plus il y avait des
des rumeurs de hausse qui commençaient à
circuler donc jusqu'à mi-2022 on a
enregistré des pics qui ne se
reproduiront pas qu'on avait jamais
connu et que je crois on ne reconna on
ne connaîtra pas avant avant un bon
moment la deuxème précaution c'est par
rapport au fameux hcsf et et les
critères du Haut Conseil de stabilité
financière alors vous permettrait de
défendre un peu les décisions de cette
instance et qui ont été elles-même
assouplies ajusté en juin puis en
décembre l'objectif du hcsf et nous
avions déjà eu l'occasion d'en parler
c'est pas de rendre le crédit immobilier
plus rare c'est de vérifier qu'il y a
pas de dérive sur les risques de
surendettement dont nous parlions à
l'instant je vais le dire pardon très
directement c'est très facile de
relancer le crédit immobilier en
risquant le surendettement des ménages
c'est très facile les États-Unis nous
fournissent le contreexemple
heureusement nous en sommes très loin en
France la crise des subprimes en
2006-2007 c'est de vouloir pousser le
crédit immobilier sans regarder la
solvibilité des ménages le rôle du hcsf
c'est de garantir que le crédit
immobilier est accessible mais qu'il ne
pousse pas au surendettement nous avions
été amenés à réagir à partir de 2020
pourquoi parce qu'on voyait une tendance
très forte à l'époque à l'allongement
constant de la durée on a mis là la
limite à 25 ans souvenez-vous il y a
quelques années le bon sens disait
plutôt 20 ans et au taux d'effort des
ménages c'est-à-dire le charge de la
mensualité par rapport à leur revenu là
aussi on disait en général un tiers nous
avons mis euh la limite à 35 hein et
puis nous avons introduit des
flexibilités c'est les fameux 20 % que
plusieurs d'entre vous ont cité dont une
flexibilité pour l'investissement
locatif si vous voulez bien je rentre
pas dans les détails nous avons un peu
assoupli ces flexibilités dans les
décisions de juin et décembre ce que je
voudrais dire avec beaucoup de
conviction et je crois que c'est une
conviction partagée par l'ensemble des
membres du HSF je n'en suis que le
rapporteur mais il y a des personnalités
qualifié il y a diverses autorités c'est
que nous sommes aujourd'hui au point
d'équilibre et que si on voulait toucher
encore aux normes du HSF on prendrait un
risque de surennettement et on ne
relancerait pas pour autant la
production de crédit immobilier donc il
n'est pas en cause pour le dire
autrement la meilleure preuve en étant
que ces fameuses flexibilités ne sont
pas utilisées aujourd'hui à plein par
les banques les 20 % ne sont utilisés
qu'à environ 15 % sur investissement
locatif dont vous avez parlé la
flexibilité est elle- même sous-utilisée
donc les banques ont les moyens de
prêter plus avec la norme hcsf
aujourd'hui je crois vraiment que c'est
un faux semblant et j'entends comme vous
un certain nombre d'acteurs qui
continuent à mettre en avant le hcsf ça
n'est pas le sujet aujourd'hui le hcsf
n'empêche pas d'avoir plus de production
de crédit immobilier alors ayant dit ça
et pardon on est un peu long sur le
sujet mais je mesure comme il est
important pour pour notre pays pour les
Français et et et pour le représentant
que vous êtes il l' aussi pour nous je
veux marquer deux points d'accord et je
crois que c'est dans ce sens qu'il faut
qu'on agisse le premier c'est que le
niveau de 9 milliards de production de
crédit nouveau ne suffit pas et donc il
faut que nous ayons là nous sommes à une
espèce de stabilité il faut que nous
ayons au long de l'année 2024 une
reprise progressive encore une fois on
ne reviendra pas au 22 ou au chiffres
avant mais je veux pas donner de chiffre
il faut une reprise graduelle de la
production de crédit immobilier je pense
qu'il y a un certain nombre d'éléments
qui sont réunis en ce sens il y
a une demande probablement des ménages
qui va être moins attentiste beaucoup de
ménages n'ont pas demandé de crédit
immobilier parce qu'ils ont attendu un
ajustement des prix qui est en train de
se produire il y a des taux du crédit
immobilier qui devrai se stabiliser et
ensuite j'espère baisser c'est la
question que plusieurs d'entre vous on
ont posé euh les taux du crédit
immobilier c'est des décisions des
banques c'est pas des décisions de la
Banque de France ou de la Banque
centrale européenne mais il y a diverses
composantes il y a les dépôts à vu qui
coûtent zéro il y a le livra qui est
stabilisé à 3 il y a les taux de marché
qui dépendent de la Banque centrale
européenne là les taux de la Banque
centrale européenne sont stables et vont
même baisser et enfin les tauxs à long
terme qui eux- mêmes ont baissé ça fait
un certain nombre d'ingrédients
favorables mais ce n'est pas moi qui
rassemble ces ingrédients pour les les
les décision de taux des banques
j'observe juste qu'il y a une certaine
tendance à la stabilisation et la baisse
et comme vous l'avez vu euh j'ai proposé
que nous revenions à la fixation
trimestrielle du taux de l'usure nous
avions beaucoup parlé l'an dernier de ce
sujet du taux de l'usure
exceptionnellement on avait accepté un
ajustement mensuel pour que on puisse
intégrer la remontée des taux et qu'on
on sort de ces taux un peu exceptionnels
à 1 et demi je crois que ça n'a plus de
raison d'être aujourd'hui donc le retour
au trimestriel est un signe de
stabilisation donc ça ça fait un certain
nombre d'éléments favorables enf
il y a la fameuse question de la volonté
de prêter des banques il y a des
facteurs de demande ils sont
prédominants il y a des facteurs de
niveau de taux mais est-ce que les
banques ont la volonté de prêter sur le
crédit immobilier j'ai entendu beaucoup
de questions de votre part sur la
question du taux de refus et de
l'augmentation du taux de refug Monsieur
K c'est l'exemple que vous ctiez que je
connais pas en particulier mais je sais
que beaucoup de
parlementaires ça nous arrive aussi
d'être saisi ont des cas qui paraissent
difficiles à expliquer de taux de refus
parce qui ne sont pas justifiés par les
normes
hcsf alors je vais à la fois prendre le
rôle inconfortable de
dire un pronostic un tout petit peu
positif sur la volonté des banques mais
en même temps d'avoir une exigence
vis-à-vis d'elle je vois aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de signes que les banques
reviennent sur le crédit immobilier
elles font des campagnes de publicité
elles sont plus proactives et cetera et
je ne peux ce matin que les inviter
fortement en ce sens une banque une
banque saine uneque solide comme les
banques françaises c'est fait pour
prêter au PME et au ménag et il y a
probablement certains acteurs qui
temporairement c'était un peu désengagé
du crédit immobilier elles n'ont aucune
raison de le faire
aujourd'hui il n'ont pas de raison de
rentabilité de liquidité et cetera ça ce
serait des
prétextes je vois objectivement une
volonté nouvelle renforcée en ce
sens le point sur lequel me semble-t-il
il faut définitivement
éclairer les emprunteurs potentiels
c'est cette question des refus alors
c'est très difficile à mesurer je veux
pas rentrer dans les débat technique
nous n'avons pas nous de mesure
objective de est-ce que les taux de
refus ont augmenté ou pas bon on pourra
y revenir si vous voulez mais ce que
j'ai proposé en la matière qui me paraît
la façon la plus simple la plus
opérationnelle pour reprendre le bot du
rapporteur général de traiter ça c'est
qu'il a une procédure de réexamen
amiable simple c'estd qu'un dossier
apparemment solvable qui est refusé peut
saisir sa banque et nous suivrons euh
les cadres et examen les banques nous
disent que bah il y aura euh
confirmation des décisions parce qu'ell
ne refusent aucun dossier solvable bah
dans ce cas-là la procédure sera
l'occasion de le montrer à minima ça
servira à ça euh et si ça permet de
réexaminer positivement un certain de
dossier tant mieux donc j'ai proposé ça
à la fin de l'année dernière le ministre
a repris ce souhait je crois qu'il est
très souhaitable maintenant que ça se
traduise dans les faits dans les
prochaines semaines c'est cette
procédure de réexamen simple accessible
transparente soit mise en place très
vite je crois que c'est la meilleure
réponse à à la question que vous avez
posé sur la volonté de prêter des
banques et et et et le taux de refus
mais je partage tout à fait le souhait
et nous le
suivrons que la production de crédit
immobilier reparte progressivement
pardon d'avoir été un peu long là-dessus
mais c'est évidemment un sujet central
euh je vais aller un peu plus vite sur
les autres questions monsieur canev sur
l'endettement public il n'a pas de
conséquences sur les fonds publics de la
Banque de France pour répondre
directement pour autant je reviend je
reviendrai tout à l'heure sur la alors
je où j'en dis un mot tout de suite sur
sur la question sur les les les pertes
que Madame briquet vous avez posé alors
c'est vrai la Banque de France comme à
peu près toutes les autres banques
centrales je je l'ai annoncé depuis un
an va faire des pertes temporaires
pendant quelques années je ne valide pas
les chiffres qui circulent parce que ça
euh ben nous les verrons au moment de la
publication des comptes 2023 de la
Banque de France donc au mois de mars
euh c'est la conséquence mécanique euh
j'allais presque dire normale de la
politique monétaire très active très en
soutien de l'activité qui a été mené
jusqu'en 2022 et dont on parlait tout à
l'heure pourquoi parce qu'il y a des
bilans de grande taille et que la
remontée des taux expose à des pertes
sur ces bilans de grande taille le point
qui est important c'est que la Banque de
France a les moyens par les provisions
qu'elle a constitué et par d'autres
moyens de couvrir ces pertes tout en
restant fond propositif et sans faire
appel à une recapitalisation publique ça
je veux le dire très
fortement et
elle a les moyens aussi de mener la
politique monétaire qui convient sa
politique monétaire ne sera pas guidé
par sa situation financière ça ça serait
une trahison du du mandat parce que
notre mandat il est guidé par l'objectif
d'inflation à 2 %. donc je confirme
effectivement que il y aura des pertes
je donne pas de de de chiffres
aujourd'hui parce que nous les verrons
en mars mais je précise que nous avons
par les provisions constituées et par
d'autres moyens la capacité à couvrir
ses pertes sans réapitalisation publique
et en restant en situation de fonds
propres positif c'est ça qui est
important je crois euh pour pour pour
les Français
euh sur très rapidement je ne peux que
vous rejoindre monsieur Canevet sur les
zones de plein emploi qui existent en
France et en particulier en Bretagne et
plus largement dans le grand Ouest je
crois que ce sont des exemples positifs
nous pouvons y arriver et sur le droit
au compte à ma connaissance les
pratiques bancaires se sont
significativement amélioré à la suite du
du décret 2022 notamment sur la
justification du refus qui qui bloquait
un peu ou ralentissait la procédure mais
on vérifiera peut-être à la suite de de
votre question question
euh madame car sur le surendettement
j'ai répondu sur le
chômage vous vouliez relativisé mon
jugement très positif j'avais pas eu
l'impression qu'il était tant que ça
parce qu'il me semble que je n ai quand
même invité je trouve qu'on parle trop
peu de chômage aujourd'hui en France
donc là je vous rejoins et que si je
peux dire la question du plein emploi a
l'air de s'identifier beaucoup à une
seule question de calendrier un
calendrier plus électoral qu'économique
ça ce n'est pas mon sujet je crois que
c'est très important que nous gardions
ce cap nous n'y sommes pas hein alors
pour prendre une image familière le
verre est à moitié plein ou à moitié
vide je crois qu'on peut décrire les
deux parties du verre sans basculer dans
un positivisme exagéré le développement
de l'apprentissage et me semble-t-il un
progrès français et vous avez raison et
pardon je n'avais pas répondu au
rapporteur général sur ce point le
miroir de nos progrès sur l'emploi parce
qu'il y en a eu même s'ils ne sont pas
suffisants le miroir c'est une
dégradation de la productivité
ça c'est mécanique si j'ose dire alors
ça n'est pas un phénomène que français
c'estàd cette dégradation de la
productivité nous la voyons partout à la
suite du covid notamment en Europe parce
que les entreprises européennes ont
gardé leur salariés alors même que
l'activité était en baisse et je crois
que c'est une bonne chose c'est une
bonne chose les entreprises américaines
ont eu du mal à
retrouver leur salaries cette question
de la productivité sera tout à fait
déterminante à l'avenir j'aurais
tendance à dire que là il y a peu un
cycle tant que nous sommes en marche
vers le plein emploi et surtout
restons-y c'est cet objectif d'emploi
qui est prioritaire plus nous allons
nous rapprocher du plein emploi plus le
fait d'améliorer la productivité de la
faire croître sera évidemment vital pour
notre croissance future mais il y a une
contradiction je dirais mécanique mais
je la résous un peu dans le temps en
disant que dans la situation de chômage
qui est la nôtre je crois que c'est bien
de donner la la la priorité à l'emploi
qui doit être un vrai emploi quifier je
relève pardon pour rester sur le verre à
moitié plein mais qui ne fait pas du
tout ignorer les progrès à faire que
dans le précédent ralentissement
économique la précédente phase
souvenez-vous nous sommes après la crise
financière en gros autour de 2012 la
France connaît un taux de chômage de
plus de 10 %. aujourd'hui nous avons le
même ralentissement économique et on est
à 7 et quelqu je crois que quelque chose
a changé pour le mieux dans l'économie
française mais il faut pas il faut pas
s'arrêter là
euh monsieur Mor je suis totalement
d'accord avec vous sur les cryptos à un
terme près que j'ai été surpris de
trouver dans votre bouche c'est le terme
de cryptoonnaie pour des raisons qui ne
vous échapperont pas nous considérons
que les crypt ne sont jamais des
monnaies ils n'ont pas de de de valeur
fiable ils ne sont pas acceptés comme
moyen universel de paiement donc nous
préférons parler de cryptoactif mais je
je pense que si je n'avais pas relevé
vous auriez été déçu
après ah oui ça mon intention était
totale après comme vous le savez nous
partagions totalement l'inspiration de
votre amendement nous l'avons totalement
soutenu après il y a eu un compromis en
CMP c'est un compromis voilà c'est un
progrès j'aurais aimé qu'on aille plus
loin dans le sens de ce que vous aviez
proposé j'ai vu ce rapport de la Cour
des comptes qui une fois n'est pas
coutume propose une augmentation des
effectifs publics notamment à la MF
peut-être s'inquiète de la CPR là je
veux vous rassurer nous avons les moyens
à la CPR de suivre la mise en œuvre de
cet agrément renforcé
oui oui oui voilà ou les amendements
2025 voilà euh oui oui je n'exclu pas
d'ailleurs si nous avons des questions
sur le plafond de les alors le je crois
que le plafond d'emploi n'est plus
strictement dans le le PF mais le
plafond de ressources il est et ce point
peut être sensible il a été relevé sur
2024 il faudra sans doute le relever à
l'avenir
mais nous avons les moyens de faire face
à cette priorité euh la vraie solution
vous l'avez dit c'est la mise en œuvre
du règlement européen Mik1 qui imposera
le l'agrément renforcé partout mais on
va faire la soudure grâce à cette
solution de compromis sur Mik 2 euh je
pense qu'effectivement c'est un champ
qui évolue très vite donc je vais pas
préjuger de ce qu'il faut dans mik2 mais
je diraiis au moins deux choses la
première c'est le bon suivi
trans-frontière des conglomérat parce
que l'expérience américaine he les
problèmes FTX et autres voir binance
plus récemment prouvent que quand on
regarde juste une entité apparemment
limitée aux crypto dans un seul pays on
manque toute une série d'interactions
qui sont souvent l'occasion des risques
voir des fraudes et la deuxième chose
c'est la fameuse finance décentralisée
ou di en anglais entre nous elle ne
porte de décentraliser que le nom parce
qu'elle est concentrée sur un certain
nombre de plateformes mais on voit
émerger un certain nombre d'acteurs
puissants à risque et je crois que là il
faut qu'on puisse suivre les choses au
fur et à mesure de de la technologie sur
la fraude auirement vous avez raison que
le le viement peut porter sur des
montants très
importants vous me permettrez là-dessus
de réserver un tout petit peu le détail
de la réponse technique je crois qu'une
mesure législative via les tiers de
confiance pourrait aider mais que nous
puissions revenir vers vous sur ce sujet
de de
préoccupation globalement la fraude
paiement quand même continue à diminuer
en France tout moyen de paiement
confondu notamment la carte mais il est
sûr qu'au fur à mesure que nos moyen de
prévention de sécurité augmente la
sophistication des fraudes elle-même
augmente et donc donc il faut que nous
restions euh très très vigilant
là-dessus euh monsieur lamenie vous avez
parlé de questions modestes elles sont
aussi importantes pour moi que pour vous
sur le maillage territorial je crois que
je vous avais dit que euh je m'apprêtais
à aller à Charleville Maisière nous
sommes vu l'année dernière j été le 20
janvier je me souviens de la date je
vous confirme et c'est un engagement
durable que la Banque de France
maintiendra son réseau de succursal dans
tous les départements j'avais été amené
à réagir à un rapport notamment de la
Cour des comptes qui proposait des
plateformes régionales et autres la
Banque de France elle est en proximité
le visage de la Banque de France est
souvent pour vous le directeur euh et
vous nous direz si nous pouvons encore
augmenter nos services mais c'est pour
nous absolument essentiel y compris pour
des raisons économiques je crois que les
ce que nous entendons dans les Conseils
Consultatifs ce que je peux dire
quelquefois au Conseil des gouverneurs
issu de la réalité de terrain des des
PME des particuliers des intervenants
sociaux c'est une grande force
euh madame Vermeillet sur la question
sur l'épargne des Français
euh alors ce sont bien majoritairement
les banques françaises ou les assureurs
français ou les gestionnaires d'actifs
français qui la Capte euh et je dirais
que nous avons un paysage qui est solide
là-dessus nous avons quatre banques
parmi les huit premières banques
européennes quatre sont françaises un
des grands assururs européen et français
puis il y a d'autres acteurs le premier
gestionnaire d'actifs européens est
français donc je crois que notre secteur
financier est plutôt une force de la
France
euh et c'est effectivement une force au
service de la souveraineté l'autonomie
stratégique et cetera si j'ai peut-être
une inquiétude elle est un peu plus
européenne je pense que la puissance de
la finance européenne globalement est
loin de valoir la puissance financière
américaine dont vous avez parlé
particulièrement en banque
d'investissement c'est un sujet qui est
peut-être moins grand public que la
banque de détail mais qui est tout à
fait stratégique pour le financement de
nos entreprises grand grandes et moyenne
donc il faut là-dessus heureusement les
banques françaises ont une capacité de
banque d'investissement plus que leurs
concurrentes européennees mais là je
crois qu'il y a un défi européen quand
j'ai parlé d'union de financement et
d'union bancaire euh l'Union bancaire
c'est aussi la capacité à constituer des
acteurs européens transfrontières qui
mobilise l'épargne globale des Européens
au service des grands investissements
européens
il faudrait pas que ça
passe en banque d'investissement
essentiellement par des banques non
européennes sur l'utilisation de
l'intelligence artificielle dans la
lutte contre la fraude nous commençons
nous inellons nous utilisons
l'intelligence artificielle depuis
longtemps à la Banque de France y
compris pour les scores sur sur les
entreprises mais évidemment c'est un
grand axe de développement pour nous
après je crois que rien ne remplace la
vigilance humaine face à l'imagination
des fraudeurs
euh monsieur le FF sur la compensation
financière des créanciers en cas
d'effacement si j'ai bien compris la
question la réponse courte et
malheureusement non et voilà le le le
risque reste celui du prêteur et si nous
nous substituons je pense qu'on voilà on
déséquilibrerait beaucoup le mécanisme
parce que là on verrait fleurir des tas
de de de de prêt de prêt à risque
heureusement ça reste un cas très
minoritaire
euh
madame lavard d'abord merci d'avoir
rendu hommage au réseau auquel
appartient la Banque de France vous me
permettrez même d'appuyer un peu plus
c'est un réseau qu' a créé la Banque de
France et qui dont le secrétariat
mondial est à Paris alors il porte un
acronyme anglais malheureusement
ngfs réseau pour verdir le le système
financier mais il a beaucoup de de
succès et nous y veillons activement
pastion fis pour
lesabors je je ne vois pas à quoi vous
faites mon le rapporteur général mais la
réponse la réponse c'est qu'il n'y en a
pas oui
et alors sur cette question de taux vert
et taux brun j'ai j'ai lu comme vous la
tribune du président de la République et
c'est une idée effectivement qui est
évoquée
périodiquement il nous semble que la
meilleure façon d'y répondre c'est la
prise en compte du risque climatique
dans l'appréciation du risque de crédit
en général et je vais prendre l'exemple
des crédit brun parce que celui-là est
je crois très parlant aujourd'hui c'est
une des choses que nous poussons avec le
fameux ngfs mais encore plus que nous
poussons très directement avec la CPR et
la supervision européenne nous obligeons
les banques à suivre le risque
climatique à les rendre publi et à les
maîtriser hein et un crédit brun CIS sur
une centrale à charbon par exemple est
un crédit qui présente davantage de
risque dans la durée parce que l'actif
correspondant va très probablement se se
dévaloriser je crois que cette approche
basée sur les risques doit rester le
cœur de l'action du superviseur et même
de la banque
central si on imaginait des taux
verts qui soient totalement indépendant
des risques je ne dis pas non là on
serait peut-être davantage dans un
mécanisme de bonification peut-être plus
de nature budgétaire mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui la prise en compte du
risque climatique progresse beaucoup
dans laallocation des crédits par
ailleurs les banques ont pris un certain
nombre engagement hein de développement
des des des crédits vers les
renouvelables et en sens inverse de de
sortie des des crédits fossiles alors
madame suné vous m'avez reproché très
très aimablement mais de ne pas avoir
mentionné le défi climatique dans mon
propos introductif je m'en excuse je
n'ai pas besoin je crois de vous
rassurer sur mon engagement personnel et
celui de la Banque de France face au
défi climatique la Banque de France a
été classée de années de suite meilleure
banque centrale du G20 dans l'engagement
climatique pas par nous-même ce qui
serait suspect mais par des ONG
internationales et nous tenons beaucoup
à cet engagement et je dirais que du
côté de la Banque centrale européenne
évidemment Christine Lagarde le le
partage la Banque centrale européenne
est elle-même pionière à l'échelle
mondiale en la matière donc encore une
fois j'avais pas besoin de vous rassurer
mais mais je je le dis fortement j'ai
presque terminé je crois il reste la
question de Monsieur Hugonet à propos du
patrimoine moine économique national
alors effectivement c'est les chiffres
que nous publions que nous avons publié
il y a quelques semaines c'est une
notion pour autant que je prends avec
prudence parce que c'est une notion
comptable et je veux pas du tout jeter
le PROE sur cet adjectif mais il se
passe notamment quelque chose qui est un
peu paradoxal apparemment paradoxal
c'est quand il y a monté des taux
d'intérêt la valeur marchande des dettes
diminueent et du coup les passifs des
agents diminuent
et on peut montrer avec cette méthode
que tout en ayant vu augmenter la dette
le patrimoine économique de l'État c'est
moins dégradé et cetera parce que les
taux d'intérêt ont mon donc c'est
extrêmement sensible à l'appréciation au
passif du du niveau des tau d'intérêt
reste une tendance qui est quand même
une tendance qui n'est pas que
française qui est une tendance tout à
fait internationale qui est que le
patrimoine des agents privés a tendance
à se développer alors que le patrimoine
public lui a tendance à se dégrader cont
tenu de la montée l'endettement une fois
que j'ai neutralisé cet effet comptable
donc les plus grands gagnants quand vous
regardez dans le patrimoine économique
national c'est les agents privés les
plus endettés et donc notamment les
entreprises il me reste l'euro numérique
peut-être résident si j'ai encore 5
minutes euh sur l'euro numérique quelle
est la
justification c'est de dire que la
monnaie depuis toujours est un
partenariat public privé nous pouvons
tous payer nos achats soit avec de la
monnaie de banque commerciale les cartes
de crédit l'échec pour ce qu' en reste
et cetera les virements bon soit avec de
la monnaie émise directement par la
Banque centrale c'est les billets et les
pièces alors dans la vie quotidienne
cette distinction apparaît un peu
théorique au aux yeux de nos concitoyens
elle a néanmoins une véritable
importance parce qu'en cas de crise la
confiance dans la monnaie centrale est
beaucoup plus forte et par ailleurs
l'existence même de cette cette monnaie
centrale est une ancre de la confiance
dans la monnaie privée pourquoi est-ce
que la monnaie de telle ou telle banque
A B ou C inspire la même confiance à nos
concitoyens ou aux entreprises que les
billets parce qu'on sait qu'elle est à
tout moment convertible échangeable en
monnaie de banque centrale alors arrive
là-dessus l'évolution technologique qui
est que la monnaie de banque commerciale
c'est beaucoup numérisé digitalisé et
cetera alors que la monnaie de
banque centrale est restée en support
papier le papier c'était un gigantesque
progrès quand il a été introduit quand
la Banque de France a été créée en 1800
souvenez-vous ENF aucun s'en souvient
mais pardon les livres d'histoire le
disent à l'époque on payait en
transportant des masses d'or et d'argent
bon c'était pas très commode donc le
papier c'était déjà une étape
technologique très importante il y a
aucune raison aujourd'hui que la monnaie
de banque centrale soit exclu du
numérique et donc l'idée de l'euro
numérique c'est d'offrir à nos
concitoyens le meilleur de la confiance
dans la monnaie publique et le meilleur
de l'innovation dans le digital de
combiner ça je dis bien offrir cette
possibilité nous n'avons pas d'objectif
de part de marché il s'agit pas d'aller
évincer la monnaie de banque commerciale
je crois que notre devoir c'est de créer
cette capacité cette possibilité ça fait
partie de la confiance dans la monnaie
mais ça sera à nos concitoyens de
déterminer comment et dans quel
proportion ils l'utiliseront alors j'ai
lu effectivement un certain nombre
d'interrogations des banques en disant
voulez faire ça sans nous vous voulez
nous désintermédier vous voulez nous
sortir nonil faut que je le redise
encore une fois ce matin et on l'a
beaucoup dit aux banques l'euronumérique
ça se fera aussi avec les banques ça
sera distribué par elle la banque
centrale n'a aucune intention d'ouvrir
des comptes il y aura un plafond de
détention qui
préservera le fait que l'essentiel du du
montant des dépôts il y aura pas
d'avantage spécifique de rémunération à
l'euro numérique par rapport à la au
dépôts et cetera hein et il y a toute
une série d'autres éléments que nous
sommes prêts à discuter avec les banques
mais je crois encore une fois que c'est
notre devoir de le proposer parce que la
première vocation d'une banque centrale
c'est d'émettre de la monnaie et il n'y
a aucune justification à dire vous
n'avez le droit d'mettre de la monnaie
que papier dans le 21e siècle le
monopole du numérique serait du côté des
banques commerciales et l'interdiction
du numérique serait du côté de la Banque
centrale ça n'a pas de sens donc ça sera
un Partena at public privé rénové et à
travers ça président peut-être pour
terminer sur ce qui est je crois le vrai
enjeu positif de cette affaire c'est de
construire une stratégie européenne
européenne des paiements adapté à l'air
numérique pourquoi parce que si nous ne
créons pas cet actif commun universel en
Europe de confiance qui est
l'uronumérique la nature ayant horreur
du vide l'alternative peut être certains
des cryptoactifs ou ce qu'on appelle de
en anglais voilà les jetons stables
stable
coins dont parlait monsieur Moret tout à
l'heure souvenez-vous du projet
Libra poussé par Facebook en 2019
c'était bien l'idée de créer un actif à
vocation universelle mais émis par une
entité privée et qui plus est une entité
non européenne qui serait utilisée
facilement par l'ensemble des citoyens
et ben je crois qu'il est très important
que nous ayons une monnaie numérique de
banque centrale
plutôt que tel ou tel actif privés qui
peuvent par ailleurs avoir leur
utilisation mais pour répondre à ce
besoin de nos concitoyens d'avoir un
actif qui soit à la fois de confiance
universel qualité de l'euro numérique et
innovant et et facile d'usage à travers
le numérique voilà c'est ça le projet il
n'est en rien dirigé contre les banques
il se fera avec elle et je crois que
voilà il faut dépasser un certain nombre
de de réflexes peut-être un peu
défensifs je j'espère que nous en sommes
là merci Monsieur le Gouverneur et merci
d'avoir répondu à l'ensemble des
questions de de nos collègues donc nous
vous reverrons l'année prochaine à à
même période peut-être un petit peu
avant si d'autres sujets se présentent
mais en tout cas merci de de répondre
toujours présent à ce rendez-vous et
bonne journée à vous tous merci beaucoup
et bonne année encore et donc nous
n'oubliez pas vos que sèes les les les
que sèes
c'est 10 € et